can
[Music]
talk very nice jacket thank
you very nice too anyway you
online
claiming claiming what
things yeah they agents yeah Allah yeah
okay show me that asent from
proof said work for the as show show me
prove so did you see the video
fromand was
shared I mean I don't mind to go outside
do you see the video that I shared from
mandar where he says that we're proud to
be agents we're proud to be a mandar
mandar said what we're proud to be
agents okayand is it wrong is it wrong
to be an agent no no no no is it wrong
wait wait wa is it wrong to be an agent
before you digress from the point is it
wait are they to
you no no not necessarily okay who are
tell me the ones that say the I've
defined it are those who say that you
cannot do inar of the rulers you can
do on everyone on anyone you can do that
except one particular group of rulers in
the Gulf you can criticize erdogan you
can criticize Hamas you can criticize
the rulers of Qatar but don't criticize
a particular set of golf rulers those
are what I Define this this is what I
Define
as is a correct so show me in their
books from their
principle that's
I you wait wait wait let me finish I'll
let you speak that's your definition is
it oblig upon everyone or you made it
yourself no no I Define what it is
that's my definition if you disagree can
we criticize rulers wait wait wait wait
before you digress you digressing again
I know online you don't want to cat You
by here digressing the point here is are
you from the schools to make groups in
Islam are you of the scholars to say can
I'm speaking my own give me speak my own
op I'm just speaking I'm not speaking my
own
op can we r no before that dig you're
digressing again are
youy can you critize the rulers can you
criticize the r can you criticize the r
why don't you answer can you criticize
rul I say yes do you say yes you say yes
or no can you criticize the rulers let
me speak okay I know you're digressing I
came to you I'm tell about because what
we know when there's a group in Islam
are Muslims yeah let discuss okay so
they are group not all of them some of
them are okay but you don't know that is
in the heart but by their actions we can
say their actions are actions of no okay
for okay as group who def them the way
SCH I I my
own no one Islamic history School said
some lame and Muslim can make group they
find a group by himself no one says that
except you I'm not I'm not defining a
group you def group I'm using a label we
can use any label you call them boot no
noop it doesn't this is semantics
doesn't matter the label that you use
let's call them bootlickers brother call
them bootlickers or flyers or bir let's
talk about birds any you want to use
like a lion he's like
fers you want to use are you going to be
serious or no let's talk about the ACT
dig don't digress no no don't digress so
because we know as
mentioned when you make a group sex
within Islam they have
to there's no se there's groups okay the
point here is the point here is you make
a group called and you don't have the
qualification to make a group within
Islam do you said that so so what you
making to them I'm I can you I can
describe people can't I you need to you
be a scholar to describe people they
don't make sex with st the point is you
can make sex from your head because you
feel like it I didn't say it's a sex
it's a it's a government sponsored
agents agents who are doing this kind of
action it's not a sex it's
complete it's something that's
completely okay are you no I'm asking I
am do you believe that's why I asked you
I asked you do you believe in
criticizing the ruler yes or no if you
say yes I'll say
yes wait
me that I am
you point here is that clearly we can
establish clearly that you made a group
and already we have established you're
not qualify to make group with in Islam
because even if they are for the sake of
argument a group that is finded by they
still group who's finding them is still
group within Islam and they are Muslims
and you not qualified to make group and
sex in is about you calling me how about
you calling me are you are you call
me this is exactly relevant to your
point you called me called me are you a
scholar so you call me
a your principle is that you can't label
people you can't call people a so I'm a
SE I never made my own SE okay Don't
Stray don't don't CH dig I know it's
easy to speak online I know here are you
struggling the point here is brother
listen I know you have to be read this
speak you have to give 5 days I know you
come here the question can we critize
the r can we
critize can let me
speak no no why you need he does he need
help you need help here here let's
switch places okay all right why you say
I got from there anyway can we criticize
the ru wait don't digress can we
criticize the r not Chris this is the
topic this is what the whole topic is he
doesn't want to answer a simple
question I you call me a because I
critici you call me a because I
criticize the rulers can we criticize
the rul I will ask the question as long
you have to establish that you made a
SE and you not qualify to make SE in
Islam and there's no group called wait
wait okay our group or not yeah they're
agents are they Muslims yes they're
Muslim if they're Muslims make into
group why H what do you mean it's sex
it's a group you're describing
people no making group this guy because
of theirs because of their
AC because of their grp look if I say
here's an
example absolutely listen someone go if
someone goes and worships the red buses
and they're a group that worships red
buses are you going to make of them or
of them are you going to make te of them
if establish they do that you're not a
scholar you're not a scholar how are you
doing how are you doing they're
worshiping red buses I'll tell you how
because there're a group they're a group
that worship the red buses wait can you
make on
them so you're making Tech fear even
more brother if someone you're making
Tech fear of them how can can I speak
you asking interrupting me the same time
you're not answering the question I am I
said if they worship abas say yeah I am
Muslim but I believe abas is God he's
careful you don't need you don't need
I'll tell you why because the SCH is
mention ask me
why no because there some issues which
for example if a Muslim comes now and he
said you know what I'm but I believe
Allah he moing Allah is he careful yeah
okay you don't need to call care because
it's
called what is known by Necessities now
come back to my point you they are you
made into Group which schols said they
are and are you qualified to make a call
Muslims who
are first let's establish that it's B no
no no you said establish just as yeah I
have many argument I have many videos I
explain with references with with proofs
with definitions I'm not going to
reproduce for this you interrup me are
you qualifi I didn't do it on my
authority many scholars have called many
scholars many all of these people that
you
callani all of these these people that
you call one name one name SCH one
schols criticized no they they said is
group they the scholars who have
criticized one I'm speaking English stop
joking around I know you need five
months to to get ready for debate I know
that now no five months No 5 minutes
name criticize rulers diging he's
digressing digressing
SCH that you can
firstly you said you
said stop pleas Al criti criticize the
Saudi rulers did he not did Alani
criticize the yes or not you asked for a
schol for a did criticize the Saudi
Scholars yes or finish finish now finish
no no answer answer the question don't
digress he
dig dig to rulers who speak about the
rulers digress by hon I'm speak about
rulers who speak about rulers we
speaking about you said Muslims and they
are Al I'm asking you simply you not
qualified to call Muslims and sunnis to
call them Al so which schols do this and
you are struggling tell me a schol I'm
asking you which scholar criticize a
ruler that's not my
question for
example wait is he is he a scholar or no
wa no scholar okay yeah he's
because whoever I name you're going to
say he's not a wait
wait show me
he I don't have the reference on
heing criticizing someone like for he's
criticizing your Scholars he's
criticizing your position
youline you don't want to talk you don't
want to talk about actual issues you
just stupid let me tweet tweet you're
making a stupid point okay no I'm not
making stupid point crize the
rulers of the
rers made of who the sud rulers it's
edit video edit it no no it's not it's
real real or how about the from B he
made of Sadam Hussein that's
sucessful Sadam and he say it's okay for
the common Layman to make of Saddam
Hussein okay they finished so is that
allowed is that correct can you can you
make take care of the rules can you make
take of the rules question you can make
take on the rulers but the squ has to
pred you accept that PR them no problem
but the point is let me go back to the
point you have to
accept he Muslim and they say Mak
Muslims he call
Muslims you made of me right here in
this are you a scholar you made wait
wait we ask about you wor you
may
which
which anyone who has a do
canone but you said is not a scholar you
saidd is
not a he
a
he has condemned that that ideology that
you
cannot
brother stop stop us my dear brothers
and sisters I ask him question I said
which Scholars called group of
Muslims you know he said to me he said
no he never called he ideology the
ideology is I from the beginning said us
I
define i define
what let
me on hist don't let me because he said
because are run by state intelligence
okay agencies for propaganda yes
purposes this is AI I've reputed this
this is no where's the date on this post
okay I'll go back to the link it's in
your channel go to it give me the I hope
you didn't delete it no no I didn't
delete anything you sure I called that
out as a as a fake they fak the screen
shout it says it's done on May the
2 while he's looking for this1 a.m.
that's what it
says what does it say it says done on
the uh May the 2nd 2023 123 a.m. that's
what and you got 26.8k views yeah it
mean and Allah knows best it's a long
tweet here did I call you guys because M
are run by state intelligence agencies
with propaganda purposes there something
else in the tweet no that's what you
wrote so you you wrote
it I haven't looked through the whole
thing
what the is let me read it here let me
read the let me read the okay because
medis are run by state intelligence
agencies for propaganda purposes they're
only concerned with politics and have
reduced the entire religion of Islam to
politics is that true yes okay wait step
by step step by step look I want to see
go back to the beginning we say want to
see the truth correct let us establish
truth and let us be if I'm wrong you say
I'm wrong okay because you want to do
things for the sake of Allah correct and
Allah told us in the
Quran whatever you going to say and I'm
going to say Allah will write it down I
mean the the will write it down we're
going to stand before Allah okay in our
classes okay show me when which Masid or
which student of knowledge Salish or
school is they occupi the lame and
Muslim with politics show me I didn't
understand what you said okay let me
repeat I speak fast sometimes I do agree
show me in which m in USA or UK or schol
are other who occupy the Muslims Layman
with politics they occupy them yeah mean
always tell them about politics they say
anyone who is commenting on politics
needs to shut up they don't no no they
don't occupy them
that how you saying rlan look at rlan
mocking and insulting erdogan mocking
and
insulting
you may take fear of the Sudanese ruler
which one was which one he he made the
the B one they Muslim they claim to be
Muslim they claimed to be Muslim they
claim
to said it was now you're changing
your
it the one he made on all the the
leaders did he
make
he made the sud claim to be
Muslim
R
pleas our I will challenge him to show
us in our we our politics rather in our
did you not talk about Palestine just a
few days ago but we occupy the Muslims
we like you you did
you're talking about it you're talking
about it you're talking about you're
condemning the Palestinians because they
have a picture
of that was your quote it got a million
views a million views can you read again
can you again was that a was that a not
so you occupied the Muslims with
politics you're talking about
Philistines you're condemning the
Palestinian he playing around he's
around so you occupied the Muslim
politics this is correct you know what
people say about me what people say
about me sh don't like to my politics
that's what people say but you did you
did talk about can you read it again can
you read it again can you read it again
please listen to what he said wait
for teach that the most important a
issue is the difference
between first first part no no he he
left it because is the first part are
run by state intelligence agencies okay
step by show me that you you call me
show me I'm I'm state agent you're doing
the work for free that's what's so sad
okay no for
heed us when you challenge him you said
do it for free he like someone me give
you money I said no for come on
man this straw man you're straw maning
my position I never said that every
person who's a medali is getting paid by
the government one name one name one the
same mandar said that there are Scholars
who are agents of the government they're
being paid by the government no problem
no problem okay
no no the of wa wait no no no don't go
here don't go no no the there were many
schoolers Pain by the
government paid by the
government it's okay to be paid by the
government then it's okay to be paid by
the government wait wait wait I'll
answer
you they used to pay the Muslim scholar
money then why are you insulted when
you're called an agent no wa why are you
insulted when I call you an agent so you
call me Agent I say that you're an agent
working for free how am agent work for
free you're promoting you're promoting
you're promoting this ideology for free
you're condemning you're condemning
Palestinians for free I didn't cond
pales yes you did you did it's on video
condemning you're
[Music]
condemning
rulers he criticizing the rulers he's
criticizing step by step carry on so he
said for free how that doesn't make any
sense now we're going to
go you how you look look look how you
firstly now you are you happy for the
books of the to be to be judge books of
[Music]
the why
call son of a m in TV
son
of anyway brother clearly not
pro all the pro are there all
the all the proof are there it's okay
it's to is okay to be an agent okay to
be an agent is it okay to be agent is it
okay to be an agent again is it okay
yes
him you see my brothers anyway
online anyway my you see how he walks
away ping him because this guy lies
online he's a liar online yeah we but
also we have to stand we against the
liar don't be with a liar
see anyway clearly has no questions he
make